hey everybody new episode 1 material
let's break it down there's so much
stuff going on
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
pretty much all these are from episode 1
so we'll just go around to all the
separate groups starting with beric
Dondarrion but there is a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so you can clearly see that
it's snowing on him quite a bit so it
looks like they're even further north
and Winterfell so somewhere between here
the gift in the wall but this picture
from Jon Snow much later in the season
where it's snowing on him in the
courtyard looks a little bit like this
picture of Barrack so they could just be
in the courtyard at Winterfell that
would be the first place to go if you
wanted to help and the interesting thing
about beric Dondarrion
is that he was actually charged by Ned
Stark to go get rid of the mountain
during the first season when he heard
that Tywin Lannister had sent him to the
Riverlands after Tyrion had been
captured by Catelyn Stark to raid the
pillage to do everything they could to
force Catelyn Tully to release Tyrion
which as you know didn't end up
happening
berrak said that he got ambushed at
members Ford
barrack is killed run through with the
mountains Lance and it becomes the
second time that Thoreau severe raises
him from the dead
the Lannisters win the battle so they
close off the kingsroad in the survivors
of barracks crew go on to form the
Brotherhood without banners which we
spent a lot of time with during season 3
they just spent all their time trying to
raid Tywin supply lines in and around
the end of the crossroads and the
whispering wood there was this really
cool quote about the whole thing where
this person named Harwin who's a member
of the Brotherhood in the books but not
on the TV show says I saw the mountain
slay Raymond Derry with a single blow so
terrible that it took Gary's arm off at
the elbow and killed the horse beneath
him - glad and wild died there Lord
Mallory was written down and drowned
we had Lions on every side talking about
the Lannisters and I thought I was
doomed with the rest but Allen shouted
commands and restored order to our ranks
in those silly horse rallied around
Thoreau's and cut our way free six core
we'd been that morning but dark no more
than two score were left and Lord beric
was gravely wounded
Thoros drew a foot of Lance from his
chest that night and poured boiling wine
into the
all that it left that reminds you when
Melisandre is sort of running her hand
over all of his scars Jon Snow looking
at all the scars on his body as he wakes
up on the table after Melisandre has
brought him back they don't go into very
great detail but you do seek because Jon
Snow has it shirt off that the wounds
eventually do heal the skin will heal
over but they never fully heal so they
walk around feeling the pain of those
just a little bit so like on very cold
days up in the North Jon Snow
will still be able to feel all six stab
wounds that he received from the rest of
the brothers The Hound is another matter
the new addition to the Brotherhood
although I don't know if you could call
him a member of the Brotherhood he's
really looking for meeting even when he
was on the quiet Isle with Ian McShane
elder brother character he wasn't really
a member of that group it was just a
transitory period and they changed that
from the books quite a bit it's an
actual island in the books this didn't
look too much like an island otherwise
Lemon cloak wouldn't have ridden up so
easily just asking for all their stuff
but if he didn't already spot it that's
actually what he's wearing he's wearing
Lemon cloaks cloak from that encounter
it'll be interesting to see if he's
still at Winterfell when Arya gets there
because if you look at this photo here
it looks like it's from the second
episode because the director that's
working with her here is the director of
the second episode and it doesn't look
like she's anywhere near Winterfell yet
it actually looks like she's closer
south maybe in one of these other towns
like castle car one is a little bit
further south the moat Cailin is even
further south than that
greywater watch there's a number of
other places like Barrow town that she
could be there was that really
interesting Hound moment during season
six where he ran into the Brotherhood
after he'd killed those people in made
that offhanded remark about knowing a
few strong women talking about Arya
talking about Brienne I definitely think
that's foreshadowing of reunion between
them but it might not happen till a
little bit later because that first
episode so much is happening but even if
the Brotherhood go north before Arya
gets there I think they'll eventually
all be on-screen together and have that
really funny awkward moment where they
sort of nodded each other especially the
hounded Brienne like Arya clearly cares
about the Hound but I love the idea of
the tension between him and Brienne he's
just such an interesting character not
someone who shows emotion but who
clearly cared about Arya so hopefully in
the way that Sir Jorah has been
trying to find meaning through Daenerys
trying to help her out to good things
hopefully that will also happen for the
hound as well but I don't think he's
going to be getting greyscale anytime
soon just a couple of washed up
characters seeking redemption you guys
can let me know do you like the Hound
better as a character or do you like Sir
Jorah better there's a whole bunch of
pictures at Winterfell itself you see
Sir Davos on a horse here this looks
like it corresponds with this picture of
Jon Snow as they're getting ready to
ride out so if it looks like Daenerys is
going to arrive at Dragonstone in
episode 1 it also looks like they're
going to decide to go to Dragonstone in
episode 1 - you may have heard - the
episodes are extra long that means they
can burn through a lot more plot than
they would normally be able to because
this would be something like episode 2
episode 3 in a normal 10 episode season
but because you only have 7 episodes you
need to establish what's going on with
all the groups and then get them
together as fast as possible so you'll
have a lot of Winterfell but probably by
the end of the episode they'll be
getting ready to move to Dragonstone to
figure out what they're going to do with
Daenerys cannot get enough of torment
here I love the fact that he always has
this weird smile on his face like he's
either excited about something really
happy when he's looking at Brienne or he
just has a wry smile like he's laughing
at the humour of the situation like when
Jon Snow had been crowned king of the
north by all the other lords he in the
wildlings were the only ones that didn't
cheer him up he was probably happy for
King crow as he calls him but they don't
bow to a king and they only followed
mance rayder because he was going to
help them out it's all about being free
so they follow John because they respect
him and they think that he's the one
that'll be able to help them but they're
not having any of this king of the north
stuff you go down to King's Landing
you see Cersei and Jaime this is sort of
like the same shot that we've seen
before from a slightly different angle
just presiding over a court you see them
in the map room that looks like they're
making their decision about where to hit
first the fact that the nearest is going
to be landing on Dragonstone in episode
1 makes me wonder where her forces are
going to attack first is it going to be
closer to King's Landing or is it going
to be from the south because as of the
final episode they had already been to
Dorne and back because you see the
Dornish ships here and her fleet that
implies that whatever happened in Dorne
is done in there
now sailing for Dragonstone as we speak
so if it wasn't clear where they're
sailing here is not for Dorne
it's actually for Dragonstone that's why
they get there in the first episode you
see her walking into the castle here but
there are a couple pictures of white
walkers behind the scenes most of this
has actually been debunked as season 5
stuff I'm not expecting to see any
actual white walkers in the first or
even second episodes maybe later most of
that's going to happen through brand
storyline he actually looks like he has
reached the wall in this picture here
he's looking way way up so it looks like
they're at the gate here and he just
staring at the massive size of it all
because it's been so long since he's
been remember that was way back at the
end of season 4 that they made it north
of the wall to find the three-eyed
Ravens tree everyone has been asking how
are they going to get south of the wall
does it have something to do with a
brand being marked by the night King
that's really the key to everything and
I do feel like he'll be able to bring
part of the wall down but in a
roundabout way even though I think that
that's what should happen there's this
big tourism thing that's going on so
because they get a lot of tax credits it
sounds like they're going to try and
leave it up as a tourist attraction
after they're done filming Game of
Thrones
you know maybe they want to use it again
in a future spinoff season if they ever
want to go back there but that would
just mean that they had to bring the
wall down completely with CG instead of
blowing it up practically like you
normally would on a set in this year of
Samwell and Gilly just looks like he's
in the still early grabbing books I know
that picture of him here
looks like he accidentally might find
something really cool while he's
clearing cobwebs that would be a really
funny way for him to find really good
information in this picture of Gilly
just looks like another version of this
picture here where they're sitting
together and she's reading about a Zora
hi whether or not she's able to actually
read or she's just staring at the page
just thinking it's really interesting it
makes sense that while they've been
there Sam wills been teaching her how to
read so even if she picked something out
about his or 'hi she'd probably say it
without understanding what it means and
then Samwell would be inspired and start
reading more about it let me know what
you guys think about these there's not a
whole lot more that they reveal other
than Sansa is just in her full goth gear
I cannot wait to see what she does with
Littlefinger it just implies that she's
gone very hardcore but she's not stabby
like Arya is so if there's going to be
any killing
done I expected to be done by aria in
the fact that she gets little fingers
Valyrian dagger makes me wonder if she's
ever going to get to use it on a white
Walker this season but his remains to be
seen whether or not she leaves with Jon
Snow's party when they go to find White
Walkers north of the wall it sounds like
she's not so the dagger itself is more
of significance to their family what
happened to brand in season one the
betrayal of Littlefinger and their
father so Valyrian steel very important
for fighting in the war for the dawn but
for now it seems like this is more
relevant to stark stuff but we're due
for a new trailer really soon leave all
your requests for bonus videos in the
comments below I'll be doing more Game
of Thrones videos as we get closer to
the season starting congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Michelle
Bennett please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details what's going to happen
next is is they'll be some new Black
Panther but then I'll be posting new
Game of Thrones in the next couple days
so while you wait for everything you can
click here for all those little trailers
that they drop recently from behind the
scenes and you can click here for all my
other season 7 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you tonight